Bu benim resmim Sevdam ilkokulda başladı
ilk okulda okurken okulun kenarına
bitişik olan rahmetli Abdurrahman
dedenin bitişik olan bahçesinde oturur
orada resimler çizerdim sarı papatyalar
birbirinden güzel renkli çiçekler orası
bana hep ilham kaynağı olmuştur ilkokul
bitip de eve döndükten sonra kız
çocuklarının okuması uygun
görülmediğinden beni de okula
göndermediler Okuyup da muhallebi olacak
denirdi hep Yarenler ile birlikte ben de
okula gidemedim Böylece köyde aileme
yardım etmeye başladım Hem yemek yapmayı
öğreniyordum hem de onlarla birlikte
tarihe gidiyordum Orada ufak da olsanız
küçük de olsanız bir işin ucundan tutmak
zorundasınız
Sen konuş bana ise öğrendiğin kendine
derdi büyükler Sabahları olduğunda neden
hep bağırırdı haydi kalkın gayri herkes
işine dağılmıştı diye ve hepimiz
traktöre biner ailecek tarlaya giderdik
Orada birbirinden güzel çiçekler
böcekler buğday başakları otların
kokusunu gökyüzü ağaçlar hepsi beni öyle
bir ilerdeki küçük parça götürdüm
kağıtları üzerine eskizler yaparak eve
gelir onun üstünde buldum Kahta'nın
üzerine resimler yapardım evimizin
önünde Bir çıkartma yer vardı tahta
taştan yapılmış onun üzerine oturur
resimleri çizerdim bazen de evin
arkasında dolanırım güneşin ilk ışıkları
karşılamak üzere doğal karşımda çok
güzel bir tablo gibiydi en ince
ayrıntısına kadar İşlenmiş ve Ben her
sabah o tabloyu görebilmek için evin
arkasındaki tepede oluyordum güneşin
ışıkları duvarlara vurmaya başladığını
O uzayan gölgeleri bi Güneşle birlikte
insanların hareketlen işi hayvanlarını
alıp yerlere götürmeleri Kuzular Kuşlar
hepsi gözümün önünde ta uzaklara
bakardım otoyolundan geçen insanlar
arabalar vardı hayal kurardım Acaba
onlar Nereye gidiyorlar ki ne
düşünüyorlar ki ne duygular içindeler ki
diye düşünürdüm bazen de acaba bizimle
aynı frekansta aynı şarkılarımı
dinliyorlar ki diye düşünürdüm kendi
kendime hayal kurardım sonra kurduğum
hayalden gittiğim yerden annemin Hadi
artık Yemek yiyeceğiz kelimesiyle geri
dönerdim dedim yapmamı büyükler çok
uygun görmezler di bazen de çevrenin
etkisiyle El adama ne der diye bana
kızarlar the Ben Harmana giderken
dağlara taşlara giderken elimdeki eski
parçalarını götürüyordum Kağıt
parçalarını ve orada resimler çiz eve
tekrar geliyordu bu res
O arayacak diye kızarlar the Oysaki ben
her sabah annemle kozalak toplamak için
gittiğim dağlara her gün tekrar tekrar
aşık oluyor eve gelip Onların
resimlerini siliyordum ve resim
yapabilmek için malzeme bulmak çok
imkansızlık köy yerinde bazen soba
kurumlarından uyanmış ağaçlardan
ben kardeşimin getirdiği atıkmatik
matbaa mürekkepleri nden resimler
yapıyordum fırçam olmadığı için de
Saçlarımdan keserek ona bir fırça
yaparak resim yapmaya devam ettim
bu çeşme başında oyalı ablaları yüzleri
kırışmış Acılar İçinde olmuş neleri
büklüm büklüm olmuş ağaçları onları hep
bakardım Bunlar Acaba ne günler geçirdi
neden bu kadar kıvrım kıvrım oldu
Bunları kimler baltaladı onlara
kişilikle ağaçlar adını takardım onlara
da resimlerimde yere derdim
ya Baba annem küçükken bana Yıldızlara
bakmayı öğretmişti onu da rahmetle
annesi öğretmiş Bak yavrum buna terazi
Yıldızı derler derdi Büyük Ayı ve Küçük
Ayı Yıldızlara da resimlerimde
kullanırdım da resim benim kendimi
kendimi ifade edebilme yolunda sanki
İçim içime sığmıyordu bir şeyler yapmak
zorundaydım köy yerindeyim ama bir
şeyler yapmalıyım Ben bir şeyler
çizmeliyim güneşin batışını doğuşunu her
şeyi çizmeliyim akşam üzeri olduğunda
TRT 2'de Bob Ross çıkardı O benim hop
amcam da ben hep beklerdim
çok Bob Ross başlardı azizlerin kırmızı
kullanıyorum ultramarin mavisi
kullanıyorum polise mavisi kullanıyorum
burada birkaç mutlu Çalık çiziyorum
derdi acaba verdim ultramarıne mavisi
nasıl bir renk Prusya mavisi nasıl bir
renk güneşin kızıllığında ki kızıllık
mıydı Azize'nin kırmızısı diye onu
eşleştirmeye başlardı Çünkü Bizim
televizyonumuz o zamanlar siyah beyazdı
ya
Daha sonra artık yapmaya çalıştığım
resimler Sanki anlatmak istediklerim
onlar değillermiş gibi hani bu yaptığım
de neler teyzeler ağaçlar çiçekler
böcekler her şeyi anlatıyorum ama
anlatamadığım bir şeyler varmış ya da
başkalarının bilmesini istemediğim
saklamak istediğim bir şeyler varmış
gibi bu sefer şöyle bir ilham geldi Bir
Kış Günü sobanın üzerinde fokur fokur
kaynamakta olan bir gücü bunu dedim alıp
bir insan şeklinde düşündüm bunu alıp
parçalama alıyım parçaladım parçalara
böldüm sonra tekrardan topladım sonra
onu bir tablonun içerisinde koyun her
şeyi kırık döküktü etrafındaki herşeyi
kırık döküktü ama ucundan hala buharlar
çıkıyordu Yani ne olursa olsun her şey
bitmiş olsa bile bir ümit varmış gibiydi
Ben o gün onu onu da simgeleşmiş Tim ve
sanki soyut çalışma bunlarla başladı
var ya da röntgen filminden esinlenerek
Yüreğim dünyada kavga ediyormuş gibiydi
Bir keresinde onu çizmiştim sonra
dinlediğim şarkılardan resimler yapmaya
başladım üçüncü mevki bekleme salonu
çıplak ayaklı bir çocuk yatıyor o
şarkıyı birkaç dinledikten sonra içimde
açıldı açıldı kapılar açıldı sonra
dinlediğim şarkılarından resmini yapmaya
başladım
Ne zaman köye
bu Haydi Kızlar Okula kampanyası için
bir okul müdürü gelmiş benim babam da o
zamanlar köy muhtarı olduğu için Evimize
çay içmeye çağırmışlar bize gelmiş biz o
zaman erkeklerin içerisinde falan pek
girmezdik sayı bırakıp gittin beni içeri
bu
O müdür bey sormuş muhtarın bu resimleri
nereden aldınız diye O da demiş ki Biz
almadık bunu kızım yaptırmış beni
içeriden çağırdılar geldim ama çekinerek
geliyorum tabi takım elbiseli kravatlı
adamlar ilk kez görüyorum şu kızım dedi
Bunları sen mi yaptın Ben yaptım Müdürüm
dedi
var bunlardan daha var mı dedi 40 kadar
falan bitirmiştim vardı onları getirdim
Bunlar çok güzeller bunlardan sana bir
sergi açalım dedi
ya Ondan sonra o resimleri alıp
götürmeden önce be okula gitti ve birkaç
gün sonra bir resim öğretmeniyle
birlikte geldi Fatma Aslında baktılar
orada bana malzeme de getirmişler Tabii
resimleri alıp Arabaya bindim götürdüler
çerçeve etmişler okulun sergi salonunu
resimleri olarak hazırlamışlar beni
çağırdılar sergiye ama Hey o kadar
heyecanlıyım ki hayatımda ilk kez bir
sergi göreceğim sergi nasıl olur Kimler
gelir kimler gider ben nasıl davranırım
nasıl yaparım hiçbir şey bilmiyorum köy
yerinde ve ilk defa olacak birşey
Üstelik bir kız çocuğu Zaten herkes çok
yadırgıyor ne ile uğraşıyorsun Ne saçma
iş falan nasıl yapacağım o kadar
heyecanlıyım ki
bu köydeki akrabalarımızı ve
köylülerimizi davet ettik bugün herhalde
Kimse gelmez diye düşündüm resimden
kimse anlamıyor musun hiç kimse gelmez
diye düşündüm gün sonra okulda kurdele
kesmek için sergi açılışında Kaymakam
hanım da Belediye Başkanı beni
çağırdıklarını da kafamı döndürüp
merdivenlere doğru baktığımda
merdivenlere dizilmiş bir sürü yaşlı
neneler
bu bastonuna dayanarak gelen dediler bir
sürü gençler tanıdığım tanımadığım bir
sürü insanlar herkes oradaydı o kadar
heyecanlandım gibi bu çok gurur verici
bir şeydi ama aynı zamanda çok heyecan
verici bir şeydi ne yapacağım ne
edeceğim hala onun duyguları içindeydi
sonra birden baktım ki Gazeteciler ve
televizyoncular beni çıkmaya başladılar
var resimlerimi ta bakarak işte bunları
sen mi yaptın bunları ne duygular içinde
yaptım küçük çalışmalar o Gizlediğim
çalışmalardan dolayı bana Sana biz
şalvarlı Picasso adına takalım dediler o
bizden biri bana şalvarlı Picasso
dediler
ama ben o zaman 25 yaşındaydım Ondan
sonra beni ortaokula kayıt ettirdiler
Ortaokulu liseyi üniversiteyi ben
dışarıdan okudum liseden sonra grafik
tasarım Mimarlık Fakültesi bölümü
kazanmıştı ama o da burslu olduğu için
Bir de yoldan dolayı sıkıntı olacağından
dolayı bize uzak geleceğinden dolayı
babamı tekrar sıkıntıya girmesin diye
Ben ondan felaket ettim okuyamadım
bölümünü alakası olmayan bir şeyi Sosyal
Hizmetler Sosyal Hizmetler okudum 2010
yılında yılın başarılı kadının ödülüne
layık Görüldü mü Bu arada oradan
kazandığım paralarla altı tane kişisel
sergi açtım bir sürü karma sergilere
katıldım festivallere bir yerlere
sürekli üretiyorum Bu arada okulda
üretiyorum aynı zamanda resimleri de
üretiyorum imkanların biraz daha
rahatlamış oldu ve köye gelen
ve onların da bakış açısı değişmiş oldu
ailemi de bakış açısı değişmiş oldu
bazen bayramlarda falan geldiklerinde
ve duvarda resimleri görünce neler şöyle
yapıyorlar Daha dünkü anlamıyorlar
resimden ama kızım ettik Şuraya bir
sarısı reydin burada biraz kırmızı
katarız ailemize bakış açısı değişti
onlarında bakış açısı değişti ve ben
ondan sonra okula devam etmeye başladım
tekrar sergiler açmaya devam ettim 2013
yılında ise sempozyumdan sonra Kazan
Belediyesi bana sen artık bizim aramızda
çalış diyerekten beni davet ettiler ve
ben Kazan Belediyesi Gençlik Merkezi'nde
resim hocası olarak çalışıyorum
o orada benim bir sürü kadınlardan ve
çocuklardan öğrencilerim var ben buraya
geleceğim söylediğinde Çok heyecanlıydım
Onlar benim sırtını sıvazlayarak beni
buraya gönderdiler ver Ver hayatımda
karşıma çıkan olayların ve insanların
hiçbir şeyin boş olmadığını gördüm
onların hepsi birer Benim öğretmenim
dibe hepside tam vaktinde gelmişlerdi
Hani bazen denize Keşke Eskiden şu
olsaydı yada Keski Eskiden böyle olsaydı
diyor ama ben her şeyi tam vaktinde
geldiğini düşünüyorum Ben yine dünyaya
tekrar gelmiş olsam yine aynı ortamda
yine aynı ailede yine aynı çevren
içerisinde olmak isterdim Bana
kattıkları ilhamlar dan dolayı hepsini
buradan şükranlarımı sunuyorum
Biz burada şunu söylemek istiyorum
insanların dünyaya bakış açılarının
farklı olması gerektiğini hacmi olan her
şeyin bir ruhu olduğunu Belki ben sen
ayağımızda tepip gittiğimiz Bir taşın
bir toprağın bilmiyorum bir ağaç
parçasının bile güruhu olduğunu onları
resimlerini konu ettiğinde Anladım
hiçbir şeyin boş Yar atılmadığını bir
kabuğun bir ağacın Ne bileyim hiçbir
canlının hiçbir yaratın boş yer
atılmadığını düşünüyorum her şeyin bir
konusu ve bir hikayesi olduğuna
inanıyorum bunu kendi hikayemi
özdeşleştirir dikten sonra ben kendi
kanaatim de böyle birşeye vardım
teşekkür ediyorum beni dinlediğiniz için